[موسيقى]
الكوكب ولكنه
معقد للغاية وهش
ويعاني من العديد من
المشكلات
تغير المناخ
وندرة المجاعة المائية
والمشاكل الصحية
مثل فيروسات السرطان وما إلى ذلك وهكذا دواليك
ولهذا السبب في عام 2015 صممت
الأمم المتحدة
وأدخلت
أهدافًا مستدامة لتطوير الويب
والتي  مترابطة
وتعمل كمخطط
لمستقبل مستدام ، وقد تم
تكييف أهداف التنمية المستدامة هذه من قبل 193 دولة
أعضاء وتم تحديدها من قبل جميع الدول
الأعضاء في الأمم المتحدة ،
ومن المتوقع أن
تكتمل هذه الأجندة بحلول عام 2030 أو أن تكون مستهدفة
اكتمل بحلول عام
2013. الشريحة التالية
نظرًا لأن خلفيتي تتعلق ببحوثي الطبية ، فقد
حصلت على درجة الدكتوراه في
بحثي الطبي ولدي أكثر من 30 عامًا
من البحث الكتابي ، قررت
المساهمة في
أهداف التنمية المستدامة هذه واختيار الصحة
كأحد أهدافي الأساسية
المساهمة في
أهداف التنمية المستدامة
في الشرائح على ما
يرام بالضبط
من أجل القيام به  لذلك قمت بتجنيد
مجموعة من الباحثين الشباب
من أجل تحقيق أهدافنا ومحاولة
المساهمة قدر الإمكان
بحلول مبتكرة للمشاكل الصحية الحالية
ومعايير رئيسية لهذا الفريق
يأتون من خلفيات مختلفة كل واحد
منهم لديه خبرة
مختلفة مختلفة  عقلية
بعضهم باحثون بعضهم
علماء والبعض منهم
مهندسين وقد وضعوا هذا في
نصيحة واحدة لماذا
لأنني كنت مهتمًا بتطوير
نماذج أولية من
المنتجات للوصول إلى السوق ولمس
المشكلة لمعالجة المشكلة
والحصول على فكرة حقيقية.  الحل الذي يمكننا معالجته
كقضايا صحية مجتمعية وعالمية معينة ،
لذا مرة أخرى العقلية
والمهارات التقنية مع معاييري لاختيار
أعضاء فريقي ،
لذلك بدأنا
بالرقم
الأول ، واختيار والذهاب إلى المجتمع
واختيار الألم الذي يجب القيام به
بالصحة وجلب هذا الألم إلى المختبر إلى
السبورة البيضاء
ثم
نبدأ في إجراء الأبحاث وإذا
وجدنا أو كنا قادرين على تطوير  هرب
حلًا مبتكرًا نحاول مقارنته
بالحلول الموجودة في
سوق السوق ، ثم إذا كان لدينا
حل مبتكر لم يتم
تطويره من قبل ، فسنقوم بالتوظيف للحصول على براءة اختراع
ثم نبدأ شركة
وأخيراً ننضم إلى
أه المسرّعات و  حاضنات
ونهج أصحاب رؤوس الأموال من أجل
البحث عن التمويل وكذلك المشورة بشأن
تطوير خطة عمل مناسبة
وخطوات للتسويق ،
سأعرض لك أربعة
حلول مختلفة تم تطويرها في
مجموعتي البحثية ، أولها مخصص للسرطان
بالطبع نحن مألوفون جدًا  مصاب
بالسرطان
وقد تعرف شخصًا مصابًا
بسرطان الثدي وسرطان البروستاتا وما
إلى ذلك في الإسلام ،
لذلك هناك أدوية للسرطان
معتمدة بالفعل من قبل إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) ورأيك
وهي متوفرة جدًا في السوق ،
فما الذي نفعله
قررنا استخدام
مواد اصطناعية  العقاقير التي لها تأثير سي بي والمرضى السامة
وتدمجها مع المنتجات الطبيعية
مثل في هذه الحالة لدينا
خطة [موسيقى]  التي تنمو في مصر ودول
شمال إفريقيا الأخرى
وتخلطها معًا وتضمينها
في ناقلات النانو الذكية لتوصيلها
إلى الأنسجة السرطانية ، لذا فإن هذا الناقل الذي يحتوي على
الأدوية الاصطناعية والمنتج الطبيعي
سيذهب ويستهدف الخلايا السرطانية
ولكن ليس الخلايا الطبيعية.  في هذه الحالة
لدينا علاج فعال للسرطان
بدون آثار جانبية خطيرة وقد
جربنا هذا قمنا بتطوير
عدة صيغ ناجحة لعلاج
سرطان الثدي وكذلك سرطان المبيض
والثاني
التحدي الثاني قادم فريقي
بالطبع
كما تعلمون  في يوم أمس ، قتل 19
حوالي 6 ملايين شخص وأصاب
أكثر من 470 مليون شخص على مستوى العالم
جميعنا عانينا من الغلاف 19 من
الإسلام ،
لذلك ربما كنت تتساءل عما إذا
كنت ستذهب لإجراء مبادلة وإما مبادلة
أو ثمار ماذا حدث لهذه العينة
جيدًا  ما حدث لهذه العينة هنا
هو
أنه حيث يتم إدخالها في
محلول معين من مواد كيميائية معينة لاستخراج
الجينوم للغلاف 19 و  d ثم يتم
وضعها في أداة مختلفة من
أجل تضخيم هذا الجينوم
واكتشافه
في مجموعتي البحثية ، قمنا بتطوير
نظامين آليين نسميهما أحدهما
على اليسار kepular والآخر على
اليمين
وهما النظامان الوحيدان  التي
تم تطويرها من قبل أي دولة عربية أو
أفريقية ، هذه هي المرة الأولى
التي نتمكن فيها من تطوير النظام ،
يمكن استخدام هذه المنصة للكشف عن
الفيروسات على سبيل المثال الكرت 19 مهما كان ما
يرونه أو hrd وما إلى ذلك وكذلك
علامات السرطان وهذا  هو لأول
مرة في كل هذه البلدان في
المنطقة
وهذا النظام له
مكانة أولى في هذا
النوع من المعرض المبتكر
مشكلة أخرى هي نزيف نزيف
خطير للغاية
كل واحد منا لديه ما بين خمسة إلى ستة
لترات من الدم وإذا  تبدأ معي ،
ستكون هذه مشكلة ويمكننا استخدام
الحياة ، لذا من المهم جدًا التوقف عن
التنفس على الفور ، لذا كان هذا
تحديًا آخر قمنا
بتجربته في مجموعتي البحثية
و  لقد طورنا إسفنجة صغيرة لطيفة جدًا
وفعالة للغاية
وتوقف النزيف فورًا في
وقت قصير جدًا ويمكنها بالفعل امتصاص
50 أو 65 وزنها من الدم ،
نقارن هذا بالعلامات التجارية الأخرى في
السوق ويمكنك رؤية واحدة على
ترك حقًا يمتص الدم بسرعة كبيرة
وكمية كبيرة جدًا من الدم ،
وقد حصل هذا النظام حقًا على
العديد من الجوائز من
العديد من الحاضنات الإقليمية
في المملكة العربية السعودية ومورجان المملكة العربية السعودية
بالإضافة إلى
المجتمع القادم في لبنان وفي الواقع لقد
فزت بالعديد من الجوائز الكبرى
لتقدير هذا  الابتكار يشبه
التحدي الصحي الأخير الذي أواجهه وهو
الوجود المؤسف
للمعادن السامة على المعادن الثقيلة في
مياه الشرب لم يكن من المفترض أن يشرب الماء
مع المعادن الثقيلة أو المعادن السامة لماذا
لأنه بمجرد دخولها الجسم حتى عند
التركيز الصغير جدًا فإنها
لا تتراكم  يذهبون إلى أي مكان يذهبون إليه
ويضعونهم داخل أجسادهم وينتظرون
هناك ثم يتراكمون
بقدر ما تشرب الماء أو البريد  استخدم الماء الذي
يستحمون به وما إلى ذلك وهكذا فإن التراكم
البيولوجي سيؤدي إلى
تلف أعضاء واسع النطاق كل ما
تسميه مشكلة الكلى حتى مشاكل الذكاء
خاصة للعالم الجديد إذا
تعرضت المرأة الحامل للمعادن الثقيلة
وهذا سيكون مشكلة
لذلك  يرجى من فريق البحث الخاص بي
بالشريحة التالية فقط
تطوير حل مبتكر لتطوير
نوع من الخطوات الورقية
وجهاز يمكننا إدخاله في الماء
ويمكننا معرفة ما إذا كانت هذه المياه
تحتوي على
زئبق الرصاص أو الكادميوم أو معادن ثقيلة أخرى
ويمكننا بالفعل معرفة هذا
التركيز  نظرًا لوجود
حدود للكشف عن هذه
المستشعرات الخاصة بالكابلات التي نطلق عليها مستشعرات العلاج الكيميائي
وفي الواقع تم
تسجيل براءة اختراع لهذه التكنولوجيا ، فقد حصلنا على نمط من
مكتب براءات الاختراع التكنولوجي
وحصلنا أيضًا على
جائزة خلال فرنسا أه مصر
بدأنا حالة العمل وحصلنا على
الكأس
جائزة من الغرفة
التجارية الفرنسية في مصر مضللة
هنا التلال
هذه هي ح  أيريس هؤلاء هم
الباحثون والعلماء والمهندسون
الذين طوروا كل هذه الابتكارات
كل منهم مصريون
كلهم ​​يأتون من
جامعات مختلفة لجامعات شابة
جامعة الإسكندرية السويس قدماء
القاهرة
مواطن أمريكي القاهرة غوتشي المستقبل بعضهم وكل
واحد منهم كان لدينا  الشغف
الذي لديهم شغف معين مع سام
موسى والأمان لديهم شغف
لأننا نحن الذين طوروا
الإسفنج المرقئ
لوقف النزيف
قرأت
هؤلاء المهتمين بصياغة
تركيبات الأدوية النبيلة الجديدة التي يمكن
استخدامها لعلاج السرطان
علي مهدي
وشارك في تطوير
النظام التشخيصي للكشف عن
الفيروسات ثم اخيرا احمد شهيد اه
ستان واحمد
هؤلاء شاركوا في تطوير
جهاز الاستشعار الكيميائي لتصوير الجنة كل
منهم
لديه عقلية فريدة لكل واحد منهم  لديهم
شغف فريد
حتى أن كل واحد منهم عمل
بجد ليس فقط لتطوير
التكنولوجيا ولكن للتأكد من أنها تنتقل إلى
المستوى التالي كنموذج أولي ثم
أخيرًا لبدء شركة ،
أنشأ فريق الطلاب هذا أربع
شركات ناشئة كفرع من
الجامعة الأمريكية في القاهرة حتى يكون
لديهم الموهبة التي لديهم التفاني
ولديهم شغف
لجعل هذا الكوكب مكانًا أفضل لحصاد
التكنولوجيا في مصر
والشرق الأوسط ولتطوير
الشركات الناشئة وخلق فرص عمل لدعم
الاقتصاد حتى يعالجوا المتاعب في
المجتمع ويدعمون أيضًا الاقتصاد
ولهذا السبب أشجع  لهم
ويدعمونها في كل مكان ، يبدو الأمر كما لو كنت
متأكدًا من
أن كل فرد منكم
لديه شغف فريد من نوعه ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى عقول فريدة وعقلية ومجموعة
فريدة من المهارات ، وبالتأكيد يمكن أن
تساهم في جعل هذا العالم
مكانًا أفضل وشكراً جزيلاً